>> Katie, I'm so unpopular. >> Don't worry, I am too. I only have 63 Facebook
friends. >> Yeah, well I only have 54 Twitter followers. >> Well, the average
number of Facebook friends is 190, so I have 127 friends less than average.
That's a lot. >> Well, the average number of Twitter followers is 208. >> So I
have 154 fewer Twitter followers. >> Ok. Well, let's look at the ratios. I have
33% of the average number of Facebook friends. >> Yeah, but even looking at it
that way, I still only have 25% of the average number of Twitter followers. I am
totally unpopular. >> I know what to do. Let's ask Chris. He has way more
Facebook friends than average. Well, a better way to look at popularity, would
be to look at the distributions. The distribution of facebook friends and
Twitter followers are normal. The standard deviation of Twitter followers is 60,
but the standard deviation of Facebook friends is only 35. So, the number of
standard deviations away from the mean is definitely a better way to look at
unpopularity.